Quorra it's question website Quora it's
a question website I'm Eddie Redmayne
and I'm going undercover on the internet
which I should feel like no one should
do it's actually me yeah no seriously it
is actually me
first up dallara el beer says do you
know what's missing in cats Eddie
Redmayne I feel that I don't have a good
enough
figure for cat and I watched the new
cats trailer the other day and it
yourselfer just look so sort of ripped
as a cat and I feel like that was
probably why I didn't get the call from
Tom Hooper but I'm not taking it
personally at all post it what is your
favourite swearword and it's a good
onomatopoeic satisfying this is rendus
I'm going to be true I've I loved worth
next MTV News says should Felicity Jones
and Eddie Redmayne do all their films
together I think I mean I would say yes
I would love to worthless Jones in this
film literally we were confined to a
basket about the sizes table for about
three months and we loved each other at
the end anyway so I think that's a
testament to extreme work conditions and
true friendship but also what happened
with this film is we got to the end of
filming and we were sitting in the
basket covered in rain and sort of
frostbite and snow and ice it's been
such a wonderful experience as my
character basic gets to pass out for a
lot of it and just be quite relaxed and
she said no it's been absolute hell from
work
I'd take because she basically had to do
a load of stunts brutal painful work the
whole way through the film I'm trying to
take that as not as a personal slight
but I would love to do all my films at
first again moving on David Lao Wai Devi
at ydvisas does anyone know why Eddie
Redmayne hasn't done another musical
he's sang so well in the film levers
rubs David I love you thank you for
being generous not sure everyone agree
with you there have been referenced to
me saying like Kermit the Frog I kind of
enjoyed singing until I saw myself in
lemmas Rob a lot of the character and
lemmy's arad stings really high it's
kind of too high for my voice I spent
most of the film kind of
doing that just doesn't doesn't it to
keep peeling when you're watching a film
and then we when we came to sing live at
the Oscar I asked the composer if there
was a chance we could sing it down a
tone or two and he was like yeah totally
why did I ask him that while we were
making a movie that movie would have
been so much less painful for me and
audience members listening anyway I
would love to do another musical one day
thanks David next BL at film Araki
replying to a quest thingy these names
I need a movie whether the big three
British in it Benedict come up Alice
Kokomo plus Eddie Redmayne and Tom
Hiddleston a war movie be cool or a
classical movie like three musketeers or
maybe a new James Bond movie Thomas bond
Eddie is the villain been as mi6 new
boss
that's quite a pitch I like the idea of
Benedict Kirkham Mullis wide widest Ben
get like a cool surname and Tom and I
don't I also caught at the end of the
three musketeers if that happens do you
think that film Araki gets like a
commission let's put that out into the
ether three musketeers that's good
except I can't grow facial hair submit
Sarah Gailey has a tick which means
she's dead important questions I had are
so far well watching people are sending
is it Scientology not as far as I was
aware I was story is a sort of big opera
based on the idea of turning all human
beings into like face cream is it
fanfiction no is it based on a point but
no Chatham taters ice-skating or
rollerblading the answer is he was
rollerblading and he became like a
fiendish rotablator for it
what is Eddie redmayne's accident there
was a little minor footnote in the
script which talked about how my
character balem abrasax that had his
throat ripped out now it was wasn't
really mentioned much in the actual film
like that for the entire movie
it was a bold choice that didn't work
very well what kind of lizard is that
man that man is a big sort of dragon
figure that was actually an actor on
stilts with lots of bubbles on his head
any remaining saying where will I go
what shall I do always gets me like I'm
here let me
love you crying emoji whatever let go
watch they do did I actually say that
you're very welcome to wikipedia says
from the age of ten Redmond attended the
Jackie Palmer stage School where he
found his love for acting and singing
alongside fellow star James Corden this
is true so Jackie Palmer stage school is
a place in High Wycombe outside of
London and I would go there at weekends
and do sort of acting and singing and
James to stay as a couple years older me
and my memory of it is he was a
brilliant street dancer and we became
pals then it's weird enough as an actor
to get to sort of work in this world and
have fun doing it and have these
extraordinary experiences but when you
get to sort of see a Powell doing at the
same time and you get to reminisce and
share the absurdity of it all it's a
it's a great bonus so I think he's
genius James next IMDB was asked to
audition for the role of kylo Ren in
Star Wars Episode seven and the force
awakens he revealed that the audition
was horrible the role eventually went to
a driver I think it was kylo Ren I was
auditioning for the reason the audition
was horrible was cuz I was doing my
Jupiter ascending voice because I've
only got one site I villain in me and
that one was a very successful Adam
driver got the part which was great for
not only the Star Wars universe but the
universe generally submit while he was
at Eton College he auditioned for the
role of Tom Marvolo riddle in Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets 2002
however he did not get the call back
from the casting director that is Terry
in fact I think they stopped the
audition before I even finished saying
the lines I was scarring loved it but
thanks for bringing it up anywhere's
colorblind this is very true yeah not
much to say to that next anywhere means
to be flat mates with fellow actors
Jamie Dornan Andrew Garfield this is
true least go to LA in January to get
out of London to try and get work in
pilot season and the actual reality is
it was just pouring with rain in London
and so we would tell all our family and
friends that we had to go look for work
in Los Angeles submit on a plane
recently I fell asleep and when I woke
up the man next to me asked excuse me
use something important and lots of look
confused because he explained I'm
because the stewardesses came over and
we're watching you sleep this is true
this happened a while back and I didn't
really know how to respond to the entire
situation so I do what I generally do
which is utterly functions take over I
just went through does Eddie Redmayne
sing anti chairs and tables in chest
voice or doesn't use falsetto on the
high notes are the high notes in empty
chairs at empty tables meant to be sang
a full set o or chest voice it's a very
intricate detail question the answer is
they're meant to be sang in chest voice
but I can't sing them and unless I'm
singing it really loudly I couldn't
reach those notes in chest voice so I
made a character choice that came out
through substance that because he was
being so internal he would sing those
early ones in falsetto
so yeah they probably should be sung in
chest voice
posted people just forget how hard your
job so easy but it's not this is from
rest time Eddie are how do you prep the
intense emotionally demanding scenes
that you're known for nailing so well
yeah it totally depends on the film and
the circumstance and a character in
theory of everything it was easy end of
scenes to play the emotion because you
spent months meeting people living with
a very brutal disease and me the hulking
family who were just so lovely and and
the reality of the tragedy was pretty
close posted with all the traveling in
different accessing characters you get
into it I wonder what is the most
British thing that's synonymous with
being back home a love of Marmite salt
vinegar squares and just goes to snakes
that are quite English and kind of
packaging hasn't really changed since
the 80s
when I get back to Heathrow I'll always
go straight to WH Smith which is a kind
of newspaper store and get a package so
I'm going to go discos and stop milling
of squares and then I feel that
[Music]
how did Eddie Redmayne through the
coloring book magic trick when I was
young I had a brother who was six years
younger than me and when I was about
nine or ten I was really into magic
there was this great magic shop in
London called Davenports which I used to
go to and I was obsessed with it and so
when I was doing the Graham Norton Show
they wanted me to do some magics they
knew I was interested in it and they
said could he find anything and the
easiest magic trick in the world that
you just have to buy I just been thrown
out of Magic Circle is this one called
the magic coloring book and it was
really good but I couldn't possibly tell
you how to do it has been hurting the
what do you think is Eddie redmayne's
best film performance I know for a fact
that the Internet is divided on this
it's either theory of everything with
Jupiter ascending depending on who who
you are posted wire bridge gentlemen so
charming like Eddie Redmayne Thomas and
David Beckham Benedict Cumberbatch et
Cie I know why Tom Hiddleston so
charming because he has a delicious
voice you want to swim in Beckham so
charming because he has extraordinary
dress sense incredibly delicate with his
feet and I what benedict is so charming
because he's a phenomenal actor and a
kind human being I'm showing by
association what is Eddie redmayne's
method of acting honestly I know went to
drama school so you always feel that
your frauding your way through acting
life from when I started to work with
really brilliant actors so you just try
and watch how they work and glean things
but I'm going to say I'm making this
moment called the trial of the chicago 7
with a group of staggering actors mark
Rylance banker and jeremy strong at
sharp Michael Keaton Frank Langella and
what's been most riveting of all in the
process is they all have completely
different processes and so we put all of
these actors into kind of one mishmash
brilliant fun to watch on a scale of one
to ten how push would you rate any red
man's accent the way thing about accents
is if you have one you kind of can't
hear it but I mean I've had some of the
most posh education imaginable so I
imagine it's probably up there in the
tens did Eddie Redmayne use a body
double for the nude scene in the Danish
girl no Eddie when did not use a body
double for the nude scene in the Danish
girl Eddie Redmayne used his own body
basically getting naked in front of lots
of people was really not that much fun
and that day was particularly
excruciating so that was bull rap man
how a British actor is different from
American actors don't really ask that
we're all so different
there's alchemy in that there's
something that's on specific generally
British actors myself included you have
you have a massive learning curve when
you start working on screen because
you're just learning from your mistakes
whereas I feel American actors are
brought up in that tradition so a much
quicker to find that okay that's it I'm
signing off the internet I kind of love
you I can hear you
[Music]